I don't know why I got so annoyed this
morning when the guys they were talking
Gary over vacation went away for two
weeks to Portugal and I get annoyed by
it you know I do you were there for two
weeks right yes it was an anniversary
trip they put together a little piece
it's annoying I mean I I don't know when
I I always think Gary's never doing any
work he's always busy he's got the Pearl
Jam concert or he's on a Saturday
vacation to Portugal today's anniversary
yeah I don't know it just seems like I
mean but these are all legitimate things
like it would be like if I took two
weeks off while the show was on you have
more than a right to be annoyed yeah
it's not a fair thing for you know then
they go Gary flew first class on the
trip and I get annoyed I I don't know I
just how do they know all this about you
Gary because they interviewed me because
here here's Gary's vacation
we went to a uh the Azores it's a
volcanic island and they they have these
uh uh holes in the ground where they put
the pots of food in and they leave them
there for six hours and the heat Cooks
them it's beef and pork and chicken and
cabbage and then we went to the
restaurant everything was about it was
amazing except that particular dish was
not very good it just wasn't good
notification
I spent a lot of time on boats a lot of
time at the pool a lot of time at the
beach I went swimming in the hot springs
and a lot of walking the eating was just
non-stop great you'll be shocked to find
out I ate quite a bit of shrimp really
more prawns and shrimp I forget what
they call but it's kind of like a paella
you know it's a it's a mix of like
risotto and different Seafoods a lot of
grilled Seafoods had a calamari with
bacon that was just ridiculous not like
what we get here like really thick
calamari and you know everything's fresh
everything's right out of the sea con
education like I usually eat a lot of
chocolate and stuff but there wasn't
really a lot of that available so
breakfast I was actually eating
theoretically healthier I would have
like a lot of pineapple and mango and
watermelon and apples the fruit with
breakfast
you know just uh a lot you know having a
good having a nice drink every night I
like tequila and uh tequila is not a big
thing over there so um drink we drank a
lot of wine we were in in one of the
areas it's a region that's known for the
wines we were in Porto so we tried port
wine because you know you have to
important tonic was the drink you know
it's all good when you're there and you
get home you're like yeah and the places
that I stayed in Portugal were great
they were all first class but listen
it's just nice to be in your bed
vacation
I don't know does it annoy you the way
it annoys me
no I I sometimes get annoyed at some of
the other things that Gary does you know
right not his vacation I guess just the
thought of Gary munching his way through
Portugal like Pac-Man as the shrimp and
calamari and chocolate and Tequila all
you know get some wine and
well he's gotta eat huh
he wouldn't be here
not a producer does anybody else get
annoyed by this who wants to talk on air
and explain to me why I'm annoyed at the
freedom the you know just the the world
galavanting all the restaurants
Jason didn't you basically go on tour
with goose and fish this summer I took a
couple nights out in Colorado yeah
I mean and I don't begrudge you you were
out doing Jason was out going to
concerts in my mind Jason Jason in my
mind I'm just telling you the way I feel
in my mind I'm not saying it's real but
in my mind Jason's working his ass off
if he takes a day off I'm like oh thank
God Jason took a day off he deserves it
I'm not picking on Jason but like Jason
cooks and he likes to smoke stuff like
he does things too on his time off right
with you it's like I'm like Gary should
be working harder you know what I mean
chilling is what you're saying yeah
right like to me Jason never chills and
I want him to take a show with you I
feel like it's like uh Gary Gary she
just took an hour of work to disguise
the fact that he's chilling at every
minute it's perception yeah yeah it's a
perception that's all it's a perceptual
thing I'm sure I'm wrong I would say
they all work hard Jason works very hard
I watch it every day I know
you're watching him work
anyway there's Gary and Gary I'm glad
you went to Portugal glad you had a good
time glad you it was great happy
anniversary there you go 30th
Anniversary happy anniversary Mary